how would you folks like to see  me and andy have an epic favorite battle  totally edible epic saber battle  come on annie come on  andy come on andy what are you doing  come on wait a minute abby i've got no  verb conan no  pep andy what's wrong you got you looked  you look terrible out here you're  sluggish don't have any energy  all right i know what's gonna help you  out old pal and that's one thing right  here  that's right a snickers bar snickers bar  yeah have a bite i've heard they're good  in situations like this  yeah huh now i'm ready  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  uh  this has been conan and andy's epic  saber battle  brought to you by snickers